finally Boris Johnson's defense his
version of events has landed at a 50 or
so page dossier and we will get through
the details in a moment but first let's
just remind you what all of this is
about obviously we know partygate was a
scandal that effectively brought down
Boris Johnson a prime minister with an
80-seat majority the Privileges
committee are looking at whether he
recklessly misled Parliament when he
said this
all guidance was followed uh completely
during number 10. I have been repeatedly
assured since these allegations emerged
that there was no party and that and
that no covid rules were broken I'm
second myself and Furious about that
to him
[Music]
that the rules
the guidance was followed and the rules
were followed at all times
foreign
report the Privileges committee said
that it must have been obvious suggested
it must have been obvious to Boris
Johnson at the time that covid rules
were being broken well let's have a look
at some of his defense which obviously
contrasts to that here he says the
committee also now appears to be
alleging that it was in some way
Reckless for me to rely on assurances
that I received from trusted advisors
that allegation is unprecedented and
absurd I was a prime minister of the
country working day and night to manage
the government's response to the
covid-19 pandemic it was self-evidently
reasonable for me to rely on assurances
that I received from my advisor the
suggestion to the contrary would have
profound and debilitating implications
for the future debate in the house and
for the ability of ministers to rely on
the advice of their officials when
answering questions in Parliament I
think you sort of get a sense of the
tone for from Boris Johnson he does seem
quite angry really the nub of his
argument is that he wasn't warned saying
that he was looking to advice from his
advisors I'll read you a second bit for
the 18th of December 2020 event I relied
on assurances I had received from my
advisors and it is clear now those
assurances were wrong as prime minister
I am reliant on advice from officials
there is nothing Reckless or
unreasonable about that I was focused on
difficult decisions concerning the
pandemic as well as other business that
the Prime Minister needs to address my
diary is packed number 10 is a complex
environment and I was constantly in and
out of the building my knowledge of what
was going on at any given time was
imperfect and mostly second hand so that
really I think goes to the core of Boris
Johnson's evidence number 10 is a
massive machine he didn't know
everything that was going on it was a
middle of a pandemic he was busy he was
relying on advice from his advisors
basically saying he knows now that the
rules were broken but at the time he
wasn't warned he didn't do anything
basically in bad faith and that is
really what we've been hearing from his
allies as well two sort of strands to
their defense won this issue of advice
but secondly about the sort of validity
of the process itself and the Privileges
committee which as you were saying for
conservative MPS are on the Privileges
committee the chair of the committee is
Labor's Harriet Harman let's have a
listen to what one of Boris Johnson's
long-time allies James dudridge has to
say
people do mislead the house by accident
you know that you you misspeak if you
say you have to understand uh every
single nuance and you're going to be
able to account based on new facts
received and punished on that basis
ministers will simply come to the
dispatch box and say I can't possibly
comment we're going to have to have an
inquiry I can't talk about that
um and that's really really corrosive
when they're actually really genuinely
trying to do a good job share openly the
best information and I know other people
to critique that and come up with a
better solution if this committee uh
says that you know we're changing rule
books here we're going on what uh
whether something was uh just misled as
opposed to intentionally or this new
term uh Reckless that will damage the
way we do politics and it will mean
ministers effectively having to gag
themselves in front of the House of
Commons
so what happens now well the Privileges
committee will be grilling the former
prime minister Boris Johnson for four
hours tomorrow that will be a
blockbuster moment Sparks will be flying
what does it mean for the current prime
minister Rishi sunak well we know that
Boris Johnson has long loomed over the
man who took over I don't think Boris
Johnson being the center of attention is
ever really good for Rishi sunak the
Privileges committee will then make a
decision recommend any punishment if
they do decide he recklessly misled
Parliament that could be something like
an apology or it could be something more
serious like a suspension from the house
even in the worst case scenario leading
to a by-election in Boris Johnson's
constituency of Uxbridge we're not there
yet that would certainly be the worst
case scenario for the Prime Minister but
his political career does hang in the
balance